[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings president
biden is calling to expand koba testing
with the emerging omicron variant
spreading globally the cdc says more
than 660 million covet tests have been
performed in the us during the pandemic
now costs are supposed to be covered
under most circumstances but as part of
our medical price roulette series in
collaboration with clear health costs
our consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner has been hearing from some
people who have been getting very large
and confusing bills anna what's going on
here
well nate good morning you know covet
tests are supposed to be covered if you
have insurance but we've been hearing
from people who've gotten bills for
hundreds or even thousands of dollars
like one texas resident who says he's
caught between a medical provider and
his insurance company
jaden yannick lost his 75 year old
grandmother to covet 19 in november
2020. she tested positive on a wednesday
and by the next week she
she was gone so last december when he
learned he may have been exposed he went
to get a test right away i wanted to be
really proactive and get a rapid test to
ensure that i didn't have the virus and
i wasn't going to be spreading that to
my family he went to the tulsa er and
hospital for a test he says he thought
was free but several months later i
received a bill for
seven hundred dollars or so how did you
feel
yeah i felt very angry
i felt deceived that bill for the
emergency room and lab fees then the
doctor's bill landed some thirteen
hundred dollars the total over four
thousand dollars but his insurer blue
cross blue shield of texas said not to
worry my insurance informed me that they
would be sending a check in the mail and
then i would just need to
send that check to the health care
provider he did receive a check which he
sent to the hospital but unbeknownst to
him he says a second check blue cross
sent him never arrived leaving him
fighting the hospital's bill and getting
collection calls for nearly a year
when we inquired tulsa er and hospital
told us they'll accept whatever money
his insurance company sends him and once
they get it yannick won't owe anything
more what if this happens to someone
else and they do truly believe that they
are personally liable for these charges
how are they going to be able to make
ends meet given where the economy is and
he's not the only one confused i can
tell you the consensus of our friends
that have heard about this
is what do you mean you got charged for
a cova test barry and jamie costanzo of
myrtle beach south carolina planned to
visit their grandchildren in september
but say they developed symptoms we
wanted to be sure that we weren't
contagious
and had cogn they went to the only
location they say had rapid tests
available that day the conway medical
center their results negative but they
did get the bills totaling some 570
dollars after their insurance paid they
tell you you're negative then they ask
you why you're here and then they look
in your ears nose and mouth and the next
thing you know you get a bill
non-covert relief
conway medical center told us the
costanzos went to the wrong place to the
hospital's emergency department triage
tent that if they wanted a free covid
test they should have gone to the free
drive through testing since they were
technically at the emergency room conway
says it was legally bound to medically
evaluate treat and discharge them in
this case for allergies treatment the
costanzos say they didn't ask for why
would i go to a hospital or to any
testing site for covid if i was there
for allergies can you explain
why is this so confusing part of it is
because our health care system is very
complicated and confusing professor
sabrina corlett of georgetown university
says examples like those are cropping up
even though a law passed last year
requires insurance companies to cover
tests and any associated treatments if
you get a physical exam or they say
let's test you for flu or other things
as well all that visit is supposed to be
covered by the insurer now does that
mean covered completely 100
well it's supposed to be and we have
heard of some providers tacking on
certain fees sometimes they're called
facility fees or emergency room fees and
it turns out that's exactly what we
found happened to the costanzos they
were each charged 771 dollars for an
emergency room fee which their insurer
would not pay in full leaving them
jointly with bills of about 570 dollars
their lesson for others if at all
possible don't go to the hospital
go to the pharmacy
well the costanzos are appealing their
bill they gave permission for the
medical center to discuss their care
with us their insurance company blue
choice health plan of south carolina did
not respond to our repeated requests for
comment as for jaden yannick his
insurance company says they're going to
issue that second check he needs to get
him out of this but in the meantime
tulsa er and hospitals tells us they've
since changed their procedures so
instead of the check going to the
patient who then has to send it to the
hospital now the checks will go directly
from blue cross blue shield over to the
hospital they also say they're following
all laws and regulations here as well
now if you have a medical cost story to
share with us that you want us to hear
about email us at healthcosts
cbsnews.com vlad
and werner with that critical reporting
as always anna thank you very much